you had crazy things happening to you
i'm the one that's in the fight but you
had lifelong friends basically
calling me a terrorist and nazi and
people that you've known foreign numbers
and you know i've deleted all social
media from my phone and which that i
should have done anyway probably
everybody should do that
um but yeah i went through i went
through some a lot of [ __ ] uh
around the time of the election and in
the months following it because i think
when you publicly came out and said that
you were voting for trump that was when
it was like yeah the gloves came off for
anybody that had just had been
tolerating
our political evolution at that time
i'm david janet and somehow for the
second time i have been tricked into
interviewing new york times best-selling
author dave rubin host of the new book
don't burn this country
dave reuben welcome to your show
thank you it's good to be here more
importantly clyde is here so
i'm going to be upstaged on my own show
by the host and the dog that's how it's
going it was part of my contract i
wasn't doing this unless he did it with
me yeah i was actually
i was just thinking was emma with us
last time we did this or was clyde emma
had just passed away right before we so
was he with us we put her down
unfortunately on february 11
2020
and the book came out in april of 2020.
we had just got clyde because that's
when the lockdowns were starting right
and we didn't want a dog for a while but
we saved this guy at that time i'm
guessing he wasn't in the studio with us
because he would have
no he was ordering well he was eating
everything including the first copy of
don't burn this book right uh but this
is very exciting we're in our new house
we're in a new house in the living room
we're in a new state yeah we're in
florida yeah the free state of florida
our entire life is different everything
about it is different yeah so what is it
that you want to talk about today what
can i do for you i wanted to jump off
with what i think is the most
interesting thing actually which is that
last time i interviewed you and we were
sitting down don't burn this book uh was
what we were promoting
and at that time you were defending
classical liberal values and i was
defending classical liberal values and
we still are defending classical liberal
values but we were not identifying
really as conservative at the time and i
think that has been probably the biggest
shift
uh culturally for us so i wanted to ask
you
what was the turning point for you
when you finally felt confident and
comfortable to start saying aye
dave rubin
a gay northeast jew conservative
first off you're a fine host excellent
question and very direct clear concise
little uh past context very nicely i
think maybe you know so you may also
want to mention that we're going to do
part of this uh on youtube and rumble
publicly the rest will be a locals
exclusive we're going to be doing part
of this on rumble and locals uh
exclusively and the rest is going to be
yeah we're going to exclusively
yeah with just a little bit just a
little bit for the whole world to see on
youtube there you go okay um
well it's funny because we you know when
we met we've been together
like 42 years or something crazy it's
been a long time you know i'm losing
count but no we've been together for
like 13 years yeah 13 years something
like that and when we first met in new
york city and you were not political at
all and i was less political but i was
always somewhat political
we would be joking because you were
always like you didn't have a credit
card at first you didn't understand like
how could you spend money you didn't
have it i didn't want a credit card
because i didn't understand the concept
of it right i thought i thought
everybody else was insane right and i
was always like ah you know you you're
you're a republican you're a republican
because you think you should only spend
what you have and all these things right
i didn't know that you could spend money
you didn't have like my parents never
told me that the concept was like
completely insane i just thought
everyone i knew had so much more money
than i did so mostly the case too right
so like we that was our running joke
right like it was like oh you're i was
always like you're a little republican
right scary um but then you know over
the course of the couple years of
writing that book and leaving the left
and getting nothing but hate from the
supposed liberals right and getting
really all of our friends basically
losing pretty much all of our friends
which it was it was losing some family
losing some family too yeah um or at
least temporarily losing some family i
always try to leave the door open for
some of these people um
at least the ones we like more you know
naturally um
but
it was it was that road we were just
kind of going down the road together
and then i think what happened was as
some people got shed out of our lives
then these other doors opened and
suddenly we were really
like look who some of our best friends
have been over the last couple years who
have we had over for dinner probably
more than anyone else it's dennis prager
and his wife sue it's larry elder and
his lady friend nina
it's candace owens and george it's it's
that whole crew of people that we were
told were the bad guys um who actually
were nothing but nice and loving and
tolerant and wonderful and i think that
kind of moved it for us at least for me
but why don't you uh answer that
question yourself i would say for me
that even by the time that we were
promoting don't burn this book i think i
think we both really knew
in our hearts at that point that
it wasn't going to be much longer that
we were going to be able to say that we
weren't you know we weren't left we
weren't right we weren't you know we
were our own thing but the truth is that
i think when trump
lost
we already you know we voted for trump
which was very different in 2020 versus
2016. i can't believe i married her
right-wing
we voted for trump but i think when he
lost that's when it was like okay
you know
screw this
like this fight is is way more important
than for me anyway way more important
than feeling judged or being afraid of
losing anybody that i was so
desperately trying to not lose in my
life and saying
yes i'm a conservative it isn't what you
think it is i don't need to defend
myself to you anymore i don't care what
you think anymore
and for me that was it i think trump
losing was when i finally realized okay
i can't afford to be coy about this
anymore and no and you had you had crazy
things happening to you i'm the one
that's in the fight but you had lifelong
friends basically
calling me a terrorist and nazi and
people that you've known for things i've
had phone numbers and you know i've
deleted all social media from my phone
and which that i should have done anyway
probably everybody should do that
um but yeah i went through i went
through some a lot of [ __ ] uh
around the time of the election and in
the months following it because i think
when you publicly came out and said that
you were voting for trump that was when
it was like yeah the gloves came off for
anybody that had just had been
tolerating our political evolution at
that time and that was so that was
september of 2020 yeah because remember
it was around this was before kovid no
no no it wasn't before cover that was no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no one before
yeah it wasn't before
the whole reason i did this interview
with you in the first place is because
we're quarantined right so two weeks to
flatten the curve if you remember we
went
with we went out to brunch one day in
l.a
with douglas marty and a friend of his
and we were driving home and we saw that
trump rally in beverly hills and we had
never been to one right we go and it was
like the happiest most joyous you
actually said that it was the closest
thing you had ever seen to a gay pride
program what i know in the good sense
the first time i ever went to a gay bar
which now i can't even imagine ever
going to a gay bar yeah but at that time
in my life at you know i don't know 19.
would we even be allowed in the gay bar
i would never want to go
maybe i don't know
um but that's what it felt like because
it was just people of all ages all races
uh it wasn't just conservatives it was
anybody that wasn't identifying with the
woke thing and
uh
i felt like for the first time i was
able to like actually be myself
in a real way because
everybody around me i knew didn't care
what i thought the fact that i was there
was enough
you have a good line on uh
conservatives and sort of why you can
consider yourself a conservative because
i think in some ways you're better at
converting people than i am people think
i'm i'm the gateway from the the
liberals to the conservatives or
something like that but you get asked
this all the time we had our uh the
woman who's helping us do some interior
design in the house she sort of figured
out who i was after a little googling
and then she kind of whispered to you
now i wasn't even there right so she
waited for you to leave and she
basically said by the way you know i i
we know we know you're a conservative
but but don't worry we don't know
anything else
and i said what do you think about
you're like you don't know where the
bodies are buried and she goes well you
know i'm guessing you know that i'm
guessing you like trump
and i said um i said perhaps but i was
like she goes i i shouldn't ask this i
shouldn't ask this but how does that
work
how does that work being gay and being
conservative and not just being gay and
being conservative but liking trump
and i said to her i was like well i'll
ask you a question i said what do you
think my views
uh on fiscal policy have anything to do
with the person that i love and she was
like fair fair true true i said what do
you think my views on foreign policy
have anything to do with the personality
what do you think my views on gun
control what do you think my views on on
school choice have anything to do with
the person that i love and she was like
i've never thought about it that way
before i never thought about isn't it
funny it's so easy to de-program these
people if you just are kind of yeah well
i was like what are you i said to her
what are you what what is your views on
school choice yeah or on parenting at
this point or on taxation is probably
the best one where's your views on
taxation have anything to do with the
person that that you you know you
married
and she has nothing she has no answer
yeah but honestly in that moment she was
like her whole world exploded yeah and
it's fun when you could see she was like
days walking out the front door that
wasn't even my intention yeah and then
by the end didn't she admit she was a
little more conservative than maybe she
was leading on or something maybe
because they want you to think that they
want you to think that they're like cool
with you or whatever i think one of the
differences between us is that i
actually and maybe i'm wrong but i
actually have no desire to change
anybody's mind in those in those
situations i don't need her to walk out
of my house feeling any differently
about anything i just want to live my
life the libertarian in me just wants to
be left alone and i just want to leave
other people alone
[Music]
[Music]
you